behind the tinted windows of this car is
the former president of Burkina Faso
bless compare returning to the country
he ruled for 27 years the man who fled
from the presidential Palace after a
popular Uprising eight years ago has
received a hero's welcome hundreds of
supporters greeted him at the airport
[Applause]
s want peace to return to our country
is the new Burkina Bay leader Colonel
well
who took power in a coup in January who
invited compare to take part in a
Reconciliation meeting with previous
presidents most of them participated in
overthrowing him in 2014. at the time
damiba was an officer of the
presidential guard taking orders from
compare before he left the country the
former strongman has been living in
Exile in neighboring Ivory Coast
in April a court in wagadugu's sentence
compared to life in prison for the
killing of the pan-african leader and
former Burkina Bay president Thomas
no justice no peace
and Burkina need Justice before any kind
of reconciliation so bless cannot come
you know like uh the Savior savior no
he must be arrested when he arrived at
the airport of Burkina Faso because he's
uh guilty so he need to go to jail
but for Damo it seems Justice can wait
Burkina Faso is battling a surge of
attacks from armed groups linked to isil
and Al-Qaeda forcing millions of people
to flee their homes compare is part of
the solution he could help bring an end
to divisions and enable military leaders
to regain control during his time in
office he was an ally to the West in
dealing with armed groups and
negotiating the release of Western
hostages
with no end in sight to the violence
comparis supporters are perhaps
nostalgic about the peace and stability
of his regime
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera